this video was made possible by
Assassin's Creed origins which is out
today when we think of ancient Egypt
most imagine sands web plains with giant
pyramids jousting up from the barren
desert juxtaposed next to the lush
meandering Nile spilling nutrients into
the surrounding floodplains to feed this
burgeoning Empire but all we have for
reference for this vision of the past
are the ancient monuments and artifacts
that remain and ancient hieroglyphs the
puzzle linguists for centuries the ways
of this ancient world is shrouded in
mystery but so when I was invited out by
Ubisoft to get a private tour of the
British Museum speak with historians and
get hands-on experience with their 3d
explorable vision of ancient Egypt and
Assassin's Creed origins to learn more I
jumped at the opportunity today we're
going to explore this ancient world and
try to uncover one of its greatest
secrets how a civilization without power
machinery managed to build those
gigantic godly structures
in our modern world these structures may
seem to some as just huge piles of rock
with modern machinery like cranes and
may be easy to take for granted the
monumental task of moving and lifting
this much material so let's put this
problem in context to understand why it
has baffled historians for centuries the
largest of the great pyramids Pyramid
Khufu was the tallest man-made structure
on earth for almost 4,000 years pyramid
Khufu contains over 2.3 million
limestone blocks each weighing an
average of 2.5 tons which formed the
interior structure of the pyramid and an
additional 200,000 blocks were used for
the smooth white stone casing which now
only exists on the upper cap but the
pyramids aren't simply giant piles of
limestone arranged nicely pyramid Khufu
incredibly contains massive interior
chambers like the King's Chamber which
is supported by massive granite beams
with the heaviest weighing about 40 tons
that's about the same as the maximum
allowable weight of a fully laden
articulated truck these stones are
located between 43 meters and 65 metres
of the pyramid just transporting the
massive stones to the site from the
quarries was a massive undertaking but
other civilisations that predate the
Egyptians have achieved similar feats
like Stonehenge or the even more ancient
Irish building of Newgrange the
limestone for the pyramids was quarried
nearby much of it quarried directly next
to the pyramids while the granite was
likely taken from Aswan and transported
to the site on boats
we know from hieroglyphs that the
Egyptians used wooden sleds to transport
heavy objects while workers lubricated
its movement with water this was simply
a problem of manpower which the wealthy
Egyptian Empire was not short on what
has fascinated me is the logistic
challenge of building a structure like
this the sequence of events and
mechanisms that these ancient engineers
used to lift these immense weights into
place are a mystery a mystery that many
have tried to solve but many theories
come up short to solve this riddle let's
start with what we do know the first
things first unless the pyramids were
truly built by aliens with anti-gravity
machines the pyramids were built from
the bottom up next because of the
precise geometric shape of the pyramids
with each side of the Great Pyramid
being 230 point 3 metres long with the
largest difference in length between the
northern and southern edge at only four
point four centimeters this level of
Accra
he could only have been possible if the
external casing stones were laid first
allowing deviations to be caught early
and corrected before the internal
structure was filled in this makes any
theories for external ramps or cranes
unlikely as they would have been
extremely difficult to attach to the
smooth external wall which was inclined
at 52 degrees instead the most prevalent
theory suggests a ramp on one side of
the pyramid that would raise width the
pyramid but this has its limit when
pulling a weight like this uphill the
force required is given by this equation
the average mass of blocks was 2.5 tons
or about 24,000 500 Newtons there were
heavier blocks but these were mainly
used in the lower levels let's set our
slope angle alpha at 7 degrees and the
coefficient of friction between two
pieces of wet wood is about 0.1 using
these figures we can calculate the force
needed to pull this weight uphill at
about five thousand 480 Newtons modern
safety guidelines say the maximum Annie
worker should pull is 225 Newtons but
since this is a prolonged track and
stopping is not an option most calculate
the max each worker would pull at 150
Newton's or about 15.3 kilograms so that
means around 36 workers would be needed
to halt this weight this figure is
reasonable but for every additional
degree of slope at least an extra three
workers will be needed which would soon
become extremely impractical the other
option of simply elongating the ramp and
maintaining the angle is completely
unfeasible as constructing the ramp
would be a bigger project in the Great
Pyramid itself like any modern
construction project these are
logistical issues the Egyptians would
have had to overcome this is the core of
engineering trying to solve problems
with the tools at hand and now we have
to reverse engineer this problem without
knowing exactly what tools the Egyptians
had one of the most convincing theories
I have seen from French architect
jean-pierre Houdin may hold the truth
for the pyramids construction
jean-pierre theorized that this external
ramp was used to construct up to the
height of the King's Chamber
at around 43 metres allowing the
heaviest granite stones used to be
hauled up this ramp granite has often
been used in grand historic buildings
for superior compressive strength
allowing the buildings to grow in size
here the granite was tasked with
supporting the immense weight of the
pyramid above the King's Chamber at this
height the majority of the volume of the
pyramid is completed but we still need a
way of transporting those final blocks
into place this is where the innovative
part of
Pierre's theory comes in he proposes
that while the first 43 meters was being
constructed the workers also built an
internal wrap which would transport
material recycled from the exterior ramp
to the top of the pyramid now this
theory should be easy to prove the
interior ramp should still exist but the
pyramid is a protected structure you
can't simply take it apart and see
what's inside but we do have tools that
can peer inside the internal structure
without damaging it one team used micro
gravity in 1986 to measure the density
of different sections of the pyramid
this research produced this image
showing a strange pattern where the
green indicates a lower density which
closely matches the pattern of Jean
Pierre's predicted internal ramp I
believe this is the most convincing
theory to date but it is yet to be
confirmed or disproven the mystery of
the pyramids construction may remain a
mystery forever but you can explore this
mysterious world and Assassin's Creed
origins which is out today I fell in
love with the Assassin's Creed franchise
when I got to explore Florence in
Assassin's Creed 2 it gave me a unique
insight into this distant world and I
got the exact same feeling exploring
Egypt in Assassin's Creed origins they
are even including a mode called
discovery tour to turn off the violence
and give you guided tours around this
beautiful recreation of the past I
really enjoyed the game if it sounds
like something you are into it check it
out with the link in the description as
always thanks for watching and thank you
to my patreon supporters for helping
this channel exists if you want to see
more content from real engineering the
links from my social media accounts are
in the description I just gave a sneak
peek for next week's video on Instagram
so if you're interested check that out
you